Facebook is dealing with a growing
threat from some members of Congress who
say they want to break up the company
CEO Mark Zuckerberg testified at a House
Committee hearing in Washington
yesterday Democrats hit him with a
barrage of criticism on election
security and other topics ed O'Keefe is
on Capitol Hill and what brought
Zuckerberg to Congress this time
well good morning Anthony he was
officially here to talk about his new
ideas for cryptocurrency but lawmakers
spent more time asking about other
subjects including civil rights and
political advertising on Facebook ahead
of the 2020 elections we faced a lot of
issues over the past few years
officially called to testify about his
ideas for new cryptocurrency lawmakers
press Mark Zuckerberg on a variety of
topics like concerns about diversity at
Facebook you have ruined the lives of
many people discriminated against them
and whether the company is doing enough
to root out sex traffickers we're
working with law enforcement and
building technical systems to identify
if you're not working hard enough sir
but it was Facebook's plan to continue
running ads from political candidates
even if they're misleading that earned
special interest it seems that a policy
that allows politicians to lie mislead
and deceive would also allow Facebook to
sell more ads to those politicians thus
making your company more money the very
small percent of our business that is
made up of political ads does not come
anywhere close to justifying the
controversy that this incurs New York
congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
asked Zuckerberg whether she'd be able
to buy ads with false information about
her liberal environmental plan do you
see a potential problem here with a
complete lack of fact-checking on
political advertisements well
congresswoman I think lying is bad and I
think if you were to run an ad that had
a lie that would be bad so you won't
take down lies or you will take down
lives I think it's just a pretty simple
yes or no in a democracy I believe that
people should be able to see for
themselves what politicians that they
may or may not vote for you won't take
some Republican lawmakers refrain from
attacks and praised his ideas comparing
Zuckerberg to the president you're both
very successful businessmen your
capitalist you're both billionaires
you've both challenged the status quo he
calls it draining the swamp you see it
as innovation as if a rough day with
lawmakers and talk about possibly
breaking up Facebook wasn't enough now
47 state attorneys general say they're
working together on a new antitrust
investigation of Facebook that comes as
some federal agencies are also
conducting antitrust investigations gale
all right
it'll keep very interesting day on
Capitol Hill thank you very much